[Music]
thank you so much for the first time in
America it's great thank you so much
it's so good to be here yeah I'm from
France every time I say to Americans I'm
from France I don't know why they come
up with random weird comments like oh
you're from France actually last year my
cousin went to Italy I don't know what
to tell them right it's that's another
country right I just started to do
stand-up in English I don't actually
really speak English I just memorized
the whole stand-up act so everything I
say scripted right even the fact that
I'm telling you that everything is
scripted it actually scripted it works
well unless I start to talk to the
audience last night in a club I was
talking to a guy and a girl sitting
front row and I said how long have you
been together he said she's my sister I
was like so is the sex still good
[Music]
I know everything right I just moved to
New York City um great city I went to
see the Statue of Liberty for the first
time never seen it before I wanted to
see life the gift we gave to you yeah we
didn't know what to get you guys you
know we were like they have everything
they're Americans you know and then we
were trying to come up with ideas what
about I don't know healthcare no they
won't like it
what about three educational oh I have
all a big statue oh yeah yeah America
are they gonna love it yeah yeah it's
gonna be great
and we built it in France right and and
made it in France and shipped it to
America Amazon Prime and you guys
received an email from Amazon one week
later saying people who bought this also
like the Eiffel Tower
New Yorker New York is great just a
little difficult to get an apartment
especially when you're not American you
know the broker asked me for nine
letters of recommendation I don't even
know nine people in America so I said to
her can you be one of those people you
may be my uber driver or so and then I
remembered I had them cousin in Brooklyn
I called up my mother and friends I said
should I call him
she said no he's old and schizophrenic I
said great more people it's great to be
here in LA and I'm single right now yeah
I know I know I know how you feel yeah
because you're not but yeah I'm single
so I've been texting a lot of American
girls it's great I don't know if I'm
getting too old or what but I don't get
the new emojis in the text I don't get
those like I was texting this girl last
night I said what about a drink right
after the show tomorrow night she said
why not and then Spanish dancer Spanish
dancer handbag two buildings a glass of
champagne firecracker a cab monkey
covering his face
and eggplant I didn't know what to do I
sent her back an ambulance wait she
responded sounds like a plan thank you
guys you've been great
[Applause]
you